lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
demostrar que las líneas paralelas
tienen la misma pendiente dibujemos unas
líneas paralelas yo afirmo que estas son
líneas paralelas ahora vamos a dibujar
unas líneas transversales
ahora vamos a dibujar una transversal
horizontal y ahora vamos a dibujar una
transversal vertical y estoy suponiendo
estoy suponiendo que esta es una línea
horizontal y esta es una línea vertical
así que serán perpendiculares ya que la
intersección de estas líneas forma un
ángulo recto y ahora voy a usar unas
propiedades de ángulos de líneas
paralelas para establecer que este
triángulo y este triángulo son
semejantes y usaremos esto para
establecer que estas líneas tienen la
misma pendiente vamos a etiquetar unos
puntos este es el punto a aquí el punto
b punto ce punto d y punto
primero vemos que el ángulo c
va a ser congruente con el ángulo a ver
ya que ambos son ángulos rectos este es
un ángulo recto y este también es un
ángulo recto también sabemos algo sobre
ángulos correspondientes en donde una
transversal atraviesa líneas paralelas
este ángulo corresponde a este ángulo si
vemos esta línea vertical que intersecta
a estas otras dos líneas
estos ángulos me dirán lo mismo serán
congruentes ahora este ángulo de este
lado del punto b también será congruente
con este ángulo de acá ya que son
ángulos verticales y ya hemos visto esto
antes varias veces así que sabemos que
este ángulo también será congruente con
este ángulo de acá a veces se les llama
ángulos internos alternos en líneas
transversales y paralelas si vemos el
triángulo cee'd y el triángulo ave y
vemos que tienen dos ángulos en común y
si tienen dos ángulos en común pues el
tercer ángulo también será el mismo ya
que este ángulo va a ser
180 menos este ángulo menos este otro
ángulo y este otro ángulo de acá también
será 180 menos estos otros dos ángulos
vemos que estos ángulos correspondientes
son iguales en ambos triángulos este
ángulo mide lo mismo que este otro
ángulo de acá este ángulo de aquí abajo
mide lo mismo que el ángulo que tenemos
aquí arriba y estos otros ángulos son
ángulos rectos así que podemos decir que
el triángulo de d es semejante al
triángulo de s por ángulo ángulo ángulo
todos los ángulos correspondientes son
congruentes así que tenemos triángulos
semejantes y en los triángulos
semejantes
la proporción de lados correspondientes
van a ser iguales podemos decir que la
proporción de b
/ ai va a ser igual a este lado / este
otro lado y a este lado que el lado le
corresponde en este otro triángulo el
lado correspondiente a de ese lado s así
que esto es igual a la proporción de cée
entre el lado de él y esto se debe a que
son triángulos semejantes así que una
vez que establecemos que estos son
triángulos semejantes podemos decir que
la proporción de los lados
correspondientes es la misma y ahora que
es la proporción de entre a pues ésta
será la pendiente de esta línea de aquí
arriba es la pendiente de ave recuerden
que la pendiente por ejemplo de esta
línea va a ser el cambio en y entre el
cambio en x así que cuando vamos de a a
b nuestro cambio en x va a ser a e y
nuestro cambio en y va a ser
o como quieran verlo esto de aquí es el
cambio en g y esto de acá es el cambio
en x y ahora veamos esta otra expresión
de aquí se entre de c
entre d este es un cambio en g y este
otro es cambio en x el cambio en g entre
el cambio en x de la línea cede de la
línea cede así que esto es la pendiente
de cde y así al establecer semejanza
entre estos triángulos podemos decir que
la proporción entre los lados
correspondientes es congruente lo que
nos demuestra que las pendientes de
estas dos líneas serán iguales y con
esto terminamos